one let's roll I was ready to double the
points let's wait for that make sure you
mute the stream no sneak attacks what is
this that's different okay I'd have to
worry about this guy coming out here so
I could whoa what is this what do we
have here on upon moves securing an
eventual queen position I imagine on c7
i guess i'm going to retain my depons
options maybe I'll go one or two who
knows who would know that answer who
would know d6d 6e five maybe I kind of
step since this pond just won a single
step maybe I could try and establish a
pawn on e4 hmm d 6 e 5 or do I just say
you know what you moved a bunch of pawns
I'm going to try and just open stuff up
now I'm not going to do that I'm gonna
go with you 5 might take a little bit
more work or not okay if d4 came well
then I'd have to be a bit more concerned
I could kick this night away what's
keeping me from doing that maybe more
pressure on the pun whoa okay so we
could have a structural change I think
this is actually good for me I think I
strike at this pawn first and then throw
in knight c6 and this is a good way to
put pressure on these guys so if this
pond ever moves you know there's some
tactical vulnerabilities for either the
night or even the bishop once a place to
be to its unprotected my bishop I
believes belongs I believe my bishop
belongs on f5 but i might want to secure
with h5 but first things first let me
just put more pressure on this guy this
might have actually been
mistake maybe I should have considered
capturing why didn't I consider that oh
well I guess we're not having that push
anyhow so maybe I don't have to prep
this Bishop f5 move with h5 would my
opponent really play g4 seems highly
committal should I be afraid pond push
this this it might actually be annoying
so let me just do this and you know what
I might want to play here or not now
this pawn is hit three times let me make
sure I defend it and let me make sure I
get off that same file is the tricky
rook so the open file Queens don't
belong in open files Brooks do I guess
if the position is a bit more simplified
then you could say all right Queen might
want to go on an open file but not here
I don't think this has my attention this
is a furthest advanced pawn for white as
this guy of course so I'm really
concerned about the support points that
that pond provides for pieces the night
in particular this move opens up the
bishop and well I have a space advantage
but my eyes are focused on d3 and d3 and
d5 and here we go Queens getting hit um
I think that night falls into the
Intolerable category he's got to go and
now I think I got to take that Bishop
and then play my night here okay let's
see who my opponent does because you
could capture that pond and that's what
was played I have the bishop pair so how
can I put to use the bishop pair does
anybody know I could grab this pawn now
wouldn't I just be up a poet after that
after the smoke clears i'm up upon but
there's a downside to that you see what
the downside is the downside is Bishop
takes pawn pawn takes Queen takes Knight
see four hits the bishop and threatens a
deadly for on d6 so this night could be
a beast very quickly
so what am I getting out I'm getting out
let me go to this diagonal instead
Bishop air to bishops adjacent diagonals
pointing right at the king could I knock
whiteout that's what I'm looking to do
can I do that let me grab this guy first
i'm also down on time against a guy
that's been flying since move one um
well i guess there goes the bishop pair
but i have an active clean this part
could still be annoying somehow we'll
see about that this guy is an issue but
what am I afraid of here Bishop here for
pressure on that Pollock I gotta do
something quick ok hit this poem again
let's keep this guy around actually that
was a bad choice when I go here that was
silly why am i playing so silly ok hang
on here are we gonna have mass exchanges
let's try that I feel like I'm missing
something
I Pam afraid definitely afraid here um
see I don't even know what that does
actually I'm probably going to end up
dropping something I feel feel like I'm
going to be dropping something yeah this
isn't so great actually I have a minute
and I need to guard like too many things
i did this rook moose i could play brook
c7 and be completely passive because i
have to be because these guys are weak
and this Bishop is awesome i don't know
why i voided the bishop exchanged I
really think this guy was going to be in
a better spot all my base points are
covered my bishops going to get kicked
away I could do this do that first maybe
induce a weakness or something so I
really don't think I have anything my
opponents saying I've seen in the side
that their own they're not good at in
games well you have a two young men and
a half advantage so I oh man that's been
there for forever let me get that resign
button oh that's so dead resigned time
ah man forks ah why did I miss that let
me let me express my train of thought
with that last move let me explain my
train of thought you're gonna have to
believe me when i say my first thought
was king here why did I do this move i'm
not even sure oh i did this move because
i was thinking with uh with the with the
bishops I want my pawns on dark and my
bishop online but uh clearly that wasn't
a good idea was that move there
previously that that move was there for
how long oh man that was there for a
while that was there ever since I moved
my rook so I would I was thinking about
this move way too late it had it after
rook c8 so we both missed it both missed
it again and then my opponent said now
I'll take because I get the
up next oh man all right good game let
me go back and flip this deadly pins
followed up with the fork um if I had to
do it over how would I do things
different let's see about this um I was
actually fine with the position i got i
really liked being able to strike at
that pond with c5 and just just some
rough thoughts before i even get to the
position my not me not considering
taking on d5 at the first available
moment I don't know why I wouldn't I why
didn't I consider it at least I don't
know if its best but I that should have
been a move I'm considering and this is
the position that i'm talking about i'm
talking about as soon as i play see 5
like this played c5 and now it's Bishop
b2 I have the option of just taking and
then even playing III and something
tells me that this is going to turn out
well I've playing against the computer
enough to know like certain positions
bad stuff starts to happen really quick
and I can see the white position
crumbling somehow I don't know if I'd be
able to rattle off the you know a series
of accurate moves to have some great
impact on the white side but this I
should definitely be considering take
with this III advance of still on Castle
and it starts ripping at the dark
squares very quickly what was played I
just I just threw my night out and there
was the capture so huh let's see I'm
still fine here I don't I don't mind
this particular structure that's what's
telling me um I think things are fine
the structure i think since i have this
pond established on e4 on Whiteside i
have that space advantage I'm liking it
I have it supported enough and these
guys are kind of stuck but this night
move really opened things up right as
soon as I ended up
shirring c4 was available for those
pieces h5 Queen see to Bishop f5 rook
here these seem all very natural is
there something better at the well my
guess the suggestion I have is for
myself to at least consider that capture
like I was saying on d4 at its earliest
moment and here is there a way to really
prevent that night from jumping in there
I really don't want to keep my queen
opposite the rook so hmm Queen here
night their jumps in this is all very
forcing hmm is there something better
than just taking the bishop it's got to
be a little bit weird yeah this this I
guess there's an issue here I don't know
that night move okay I have the bishop
pair but that's going to be very
short-lived and after the smoke clears
it's hard to say that I'm any i'm no
better if i'm better in any way right
now would be in the form of the bishop
pair without that I don't have much
going on the bishop it then comes down
to a pawn structure and be bishops and
also I guess you could view it as who
has better control of the open file and
those three things right there that it
just rattled off I'll tip in blacks
favor so that's what makes me want to
hit the rewind button and questioned
some earlier choices right here
capturing the bishops seems to not be
right do I have another option again
capturing here like I was saying pawn
takes with tonight c4 to d6 that's just
you know how it works with the tricky
night so I don't know I think it's even
further back maybe all the way towards
that middle game let's see no I was
saying that I'm fun I think I'm okay
here but am I maybe I need to find a
better move here this night d5 move is
just a pain
I don't know what a pain I don't know
what more to suggest I guess the the
earliest point I'm not sure how to
accurately assess this particular
position I could certainly use more
experience with that maybe even throw it
up against a computer and see what sort
of stuff it's saying but anyhow good
game yeah totally missed that pin I
should have been saying to myself as
soon as the [ __ ] the app to avoid the
bishop exchange also was my bishop
really better than his no I should be
exchanging that in playing just a heavy
piece end game so that's another small
improvement at a point where i'm already
slightly worse in a more simplified
position this this pot on e4 i think is
more of a liability than an asset in the
middle game okay maybe i could turn it
into something that's more but more
simplified the more simplified the
position maybe the more advanced pond is
vulnerability so my opponent played well
occupies control over d and i just
totally missed that very good okay let
me close out